bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
cet après-midi une audition sur la mise
en œuvre de l'écotaxe poids lourd alors
vous le savez le Sénat a créé une
commission d'enquête sur cette mesure
quels sont les modalités du montage
juridique et financier pour la mise en
œuvre de cette écota poids lourd combien
cela va-t-il coûter à l'état voilà les
questions que se posent les sénateurs et
nous on se retrouve tout de suite après
mes chers collègues alors nous allons
auditionner maintenant Monsieur Daniel
bursau directeur général des
infrastructures des transports et de la
mer je vous rappelle que nous avons déjà
reçu trois de ces collaborateurs
Monsieur Michel heremu chef de
département d'expertise des partenariats
publics privés et de conduite des
projets délégués et puis nous avons reçu
également Monsieur Antoine maord et
Olivier
ca de la mission de la tarification lors
de toutes nos auditions nous avons
entendu que la responsabilité de
l'initiative des choix de la négociation
de la conduite du projetcotaxe relevé
quasi exclusivement de la
DGITM que vous dirigez monsieur bursau
depuis le début des
opérations la direction génér
de la douane et des droits indirects
elle-même a renvoyé vers vous je dois le
dire la recherche d'explication
concernant
l'évolution du projet initial et de son
coûte vous avez reçu Monsieur directeur
général un questionnaire détaillé auquel
vos
collaborateurs je crois nont pu répondre
dans son
intégralité nous souhaitons en tout cas
que vous puissiez nous apporter
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des réponses mais
mais aussi que vous nous éclairiez sur
le circuit de la prise de décision
concernant ce dossier de de
l'écotaxe mes questions nos questions ce
sont les suivantes avez-vous décidé seul
comment avez-vous utilisé
l'expertise des autres services
etmission de l'État selon quelle
périodicité et quelle modalité et
jusqu'à quelle degré de précision vous
avez tenu les différents ministres
informés de la procédure
quelle part avez-vous prise dans la
décision de suspension là nous rentrons
dans l'actualité et quel est aujourd'hui
votre rôle dans une éventuelle négoci
négociation avec le le prestataire je
vous informe que cette audition est
ouverte au public à la presse qu'elle
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo ainsi
que d'un compte rendu publié je vous
rappelle que conformément au termes de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires votre
audition est doit se tenir sous serment
je vous rappelle également qu'en cas de
faux témoignage les personnes entendues
sont passies des peines prévues par les
articles 434 13 434 14 et 434 15 du code
pénal euh monsieur burceau je vous
demande de prêter serment de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité levez la
main droite et dites je le jure je je le
jure merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur je vais donc vous donner la
parole pour comme convenu pour un exposé
euh liminire d'une dizaine de minutes si
vous êtes d'accord et puis à la suite
duquel madame le rapporteur madame
Virginie Cless vous interrogera ainsi
que les membres de la commission et
moi-même voilà vous avez la
parole madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur puisque vous connaissez
maintenant parfaitement l'historique du
projet contenu des personnes que vous
avez auditionné je rappellerai
simplement qu'une commande politique
forte a été passée à la DGITM dans le
cadre du Grenel de l'environnement et
que le ministre même les ministres en
charge ont régulièrement insisté sur
l'importance qu'ils accordaient à ce
dossier et sur la nécessité d'aller le
plus rapidement possible les objectifs
écologiques qui étaient recherchés par
la mise en œuvre de cette taxe étai vous
le savez de favoriser le report modal et
d'inciter à la rationalisation des
chaînes logistiques il s'agissait aussi
bien évidemment de mettre en place un
financement pérenne de la fit pour
assurer la maintenance et la
modernisation nos infrastructures de
transport dont vous connaissez la
situation que ce soit dans le domaine
routier ferroviaire ou fluvial à cet
égard l'exemple de l'Allemagne est é
loquant depuis la mise en place de la c
le réseau autoroutier qui était dans un
état degradation avancée connaît une
nouvelle jeunesse dès lors il
m'appartenait en tant que DGITM de
mettre en place en lien étroit et
permanent avec la Direction générale des
droits des douanes et des droits
indirects une structure et un processus
permettant de répondre techniquement et
juridiquement à cette commande tout en
s'appuyant en tant que de besoins sur
les comp compétences existant dans nos
ministères respectifs mes collaborateurs
ainsi que les deux directeurs généraux
successifs de la GDI ont eu l'occasion
de vous fournir des précisions à ce
sujet lors de leurs auditions j'ai la
prétention de penser que nonobstant les
obstacles de toutes sortes dont une
procédure dont vous connaissez l'issue
au Conseil d'État et les critiques
formulées la DGITM en binôme avec la DG
DDI a répondu correctement à cette
commande et a conduit ce projet en toute
légalité et transparence certes depuis
la signature du contrat ecomov des
retards dans la réalisation du
dispositif sont apparus donc je pense
qu'ils sont en quasi totalité attribua à
cette société même si elle le conteste
ça fait l'objet de discussion que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure madame la
Présidente par ailleurs c'est un point
que je voulais souligner jusqu'à août
2013 aucun des dispositifs de contrôle
n'avait été détruit le premier ayant été
installé le 31 janvier 2012 ce qui
pouvait laisser penser qu'il existait
une certaine acceptabilité sociale du
projet dont le démarrage était tout
proche vous savez ce qui est ensuite
advenu en octobre 2013 je voilà ma
déclaration préliminaire madame la
Présidente je ne veux pas en dire plus
je suis à votre disposition pour
répondre dans la mesure de mes moyens à
vos questions merci Monsieur le
Directeur madame le rapporteur
oui merci madame la Présidente première
question Monsieur le Directeur vous
venez de de nous dire que vous estimez
que la plupart des retards sont
essentiellement attribuable à la société
ecomov en tout cas à l'heure actuelle et
peut-être jusqu'avant la suspension de
écotaxe est-ce que c'était pas un petit
peu prévisible quand même qu'en
choisissant une technologie très
nouvelle et puis une société euh qui
n'affichait en plus que 30 millions de
de de fonds propres dans dans le capital
et cetera est-ce que c'était pas un peu
prévisible qu'il y aurait des retards
est-ce que les les délais initiaux
autrement dit n'ont pas déjà été
calculés un peu trop
justes un bouton on me donne la parole
automatiquement c'est ça ouais euh sur
cette question euh le résultat
effectivement de la de la consultation a
été ce qu'il a été il a été évalué
d'abord par mes
services le rapport qui a été fait par
mes services a été examiné par la
commission consultative qui a été mise
en place je pense que on vous a vous a
tenu au courant de de de ce qui était
cette commission consultative qui a
estimé que les délais qui étaient
proposés étaiit crédibl euh sachant que
le les délais qui étaient proposés par
les concurrents était certes supérieur
mais pas de manière substantielle donc
nous avons pensé de l'origine que le
délai de de réalisation certes était
extrêmement serré mais n'était pas
irréaliste sur le coup sur le coup
ensuite entre la l'évaluation préalable
et et la signature du contrat ou même
l'avis de de la map sur le sujet
l'évaluation du coût est passée de 231
millions de d'euros à 650 donc on a eu
des premiers éléments d'explication sur
C sur cette évolution qu je pense qu'on
peut la qualifier de de dérive hein sans
sans être péjoratif du tout passer de
231 à 650 millions d'euros c'est quand
même important est-ce que ça a fait
l'objet de note est-ce que ça a fait
l'objet d'un suivi euh est-ce que ça
fait l'objet de de de rapport auprès des
des ministres ou des instances
concernées al à ma connaissance euh et
de mémoire euh je n'ai pas souvenir
d'avoir fait de rapport spécifique au
ministres concernés sur le sujet euh
simplement ça apparaissait à l'évidence
comme étant le résultat de la
consultation qui a été qui a été mené
euh donc par contre évidemment les
ministres ont eu connaissance avant de
faire le choix définitif du du
classement qui a été qui a été effectué
euh je n'ai pas fait à ma connaissance
et je parle soucèrement donc je garderai
de dire que j'en suis sûr mais je n'ai
pas de souvenir d'avir fait note
explicite sur le sujet euh encore une
fois celle-ci se déduisant de la du Rapp
rapport du rapport qui a été fait à la
commission consultative et qui a été
remis au ministrees ensuite pour qu'ils
établissent pour qu'ils établissent le
classement je je voudrais juste dire sur
ce point qui est effectivement un point
important déjà pour que
on on soit au clair sur de quel chiffr
on
parle d'abord il y a un sujet qui
est les modalités de prise en charge des
coûts de conception et de réalisation
des équipements embarqués le montant
initial 231 millions que vous évoquez
qui figurait dans les l'évaluation
préalable il ne prenait en compte que
les éléments embarqués des nonabonnés
euh les coûts estimés donc des
équipements embarqués des nonabonnés
s'élevaient à 71 millions d'euros en
utilisant les technologies dit GNSS et à
3 million d'euros en dcrc bon je veux
pas faire dans détails trop technique d'
autant que je suis pas un spécialiste
ceux des abonnés s'établissaient à 96
millions d'euros en GNSS et à 14
millions d'euros en dcrc pris en charge
à travers les C coup d'exploitation via
la rémunération annuelle des SHT donc
les chiffres qu'il faut comparer je vous
mettrai ça par écrit parce que c'est
effectivement assez compliqué euh les
investissements évaluation préalable en
réalité c'était 327 millions d'euros si
on intègre cette ce coût supplémentaire
qui nétait effectivement pas intégré
dans l'évaluation préalable il
s'agissait par ailleurs d'une estimation
en valeur août 2008 les investissements
descov les 650 millions d'euros que vous
évoquez à juste titre sont chiffrés en
valeur fin 2 11 et il comprennent 67
millions d'euros de frais de financement
et impôts qui n'étaient effectivement
pas intégrés dans le calcul qui était
uniquement un chiffre d'investissement
brut donc les chiffres qu'il faut
vraiment comparer encore une fois il y a
effectivement comme vous l' indiquz un
grand écart qui reste 327 millions
d'euros 2008 et 581 millions d'euros
2011 c'est vraiment la base quand
compare toutes chos égal par ailleurs
sur laquelle il faut se se baser de ce
que l'on
a reg regardé à nouveau les différences
proviennent du du dispositif de contrôle
qui est passé de 76 à 198 million
d'euros et essentiellement du système
central qui est passé effectivement de
38 à 135 millions
d'euros encore une fois on vous donnera
donc du coup dans la mesure des des
possibles parce qu'il faut aller
rechercher dans tous les dossiers le
détail effectivement de ces évolutions
je
rajouterais que ce qui est intéressant
c'est de comparer les coûts globaux et
que il y a aussi eu une augmentation
sensible sur le réseau de distribution
en ce qui concerne les estimations des
investissements puisqu'on avait imaginé
dans un premier temps que c'était du
personnel qui serait mis en place et
qu'en fait on a finalement dans projet
final prévu des des comment dirais-je
des systèmes de contrôle des systèmes de
distribution automatisé qui du coup sont
inclus dans le dans l'investissement
donc sur ces points là j'essaierai de
vous donner des des précisions écrites
plus plus précises mais voilà les
grandes explications en fait de cet
écart de
C mais enfin justement je suis quand
même enfin je persiste à être un petit
peu étonné parce que on on dit depuis le
début et je crois que personne ne le
conteste ici c'était déjà un dossier
complexe euh difficile à à mener donc il
me semble que dès le début il aurait
fallu peut-être s'accrocher de très très
près à à avoir des définition très
précise à savoir de quoi on parle de
façon très précise il y avait déjà me
semble-t-il suffisamment de vagu et de
flou sur un certain nombre d'évaluation
donc je je m'étonne vraiment que ce soit
aujourd'hui que vous me disiez on va
rechercher on va vous expliquer pourquoi
il me semble que je vous ai donné des
explications madame la rapporteur
essentielle des des écarts et des
dérives le les estimations s'étent
fondées
euh deux mots de plus on fait des
estimations sur un système effectivement
très complexe comme vous le dites euh
qui n'a pas de précédent en tout cas
dans dans notre pays on s'est entouré de
toutes les de toutes les conseils
possibles pour faire ces estimations
ensuite c'est le marché qui a répondu et
encore une fois il y a eu trois
concurrents euh qui ont répondu à cette
consultation euh les trois concurrents
là aussi on parlait d'lai tout à l'heure
les trois concurrents étaient dans ces
dans ces ordres de grandeur de prix donc
une une solution effectivement et un
projet très innovant très complexe ça je
je ne peux qu'agrer avec vous c'est pour
ça que je suis ici aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs euh et derrière des offres
économiques qui ont été qui ont été
remises et qui sont celles qui ceux
qu'elles sont ces montants de prix là
quand ils sont arrivés les premiers les
premiers montants ils vous ont surpris
vous vous avez trouvé c'était ceux à
quoi vous attendiez les les tous
premiers montants je parle sous contrôle
de mes collaborateur les tout premiers
montants dans les offres initiales
étaient encore plus élevé donc on avait
été effectivement très surpris euh et
effectivement quand on a regardé après
les offres final je pense qu'on a des
raisons qu' a des raisons objectifes qui
aboutisent à ces
coûts sur les augmentations moi j'avais
une question je redonne la parole à Mame
rapporteur est-ce qu'il y a eu des
modification enfin des des comment dire
des surcoûtes par rapport au au
chiffrage réalisé à la date de de la
signature du contrat est-ce qu'il y en a
eu après la date en surcoutte après la
date de signature et est-ce que c'est
s'il y en a eu ça a été pris en charge
par eomove alors comme vous le savez sur
ce point
précis le contrat il est passé avec des
prix déterminés forfaitairement qui sont
ceux donc qui ont été rappelés par
Madame la rapporteur le contrat n'a
évidemment pas été modifié depuis qu'il
a été passé et donc tout surcout dans la
R tion qui des prestations y compris ce
qui serait Liu à des retards qui sont
dus donc à la ecomove sont à la charge
de cette société sauf sauf à ce que dans
les discussions que nous allons avoir
ensuite à ce que la société puisse
prouver que l'État est responsable de
ces surcout mais pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas entamé de discussion sur ce
point
précis al toujours pour rester un petit
peu sur ce cette thématique de la
complexité technique ou technologique
j'ai vu le terme dans dans les rapports
ort d'analyse d'offre et et dans
d'autres documents de
démonstrateur qu'est-ce que c'était que
le démonstrateur à quoi servait-il quel
était son rôle est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un petit peu si c'était
quelqu'un qui était chargé de montrer
comment le matériel
fonctionnait
alors le le démonstrateur
euh l'État dans le CRE du du dialogue
compétitif a souhaité s'assurer que les
candidats auraient les expertises et les
capacit
technique pour développer et mettre en
œuvre les composants qui interviennent
dans les sous-ensembles sensibles du
dispositif basé sur les technologies
comme on l'a on l'a déjà dit qui étit
extrêmement spécifique et innovante on a
donc demandé au candidats de fournir un
démonstrateur dans le cadre de la
proposition initiale ça correspond ce
démonstrateur à toute ou partie d'un
système technique à développer qui
permet d'apprécier la robustesse et le
je dirais le niveau de maturité d'une
solution technique en tant qu' répond à
des fonctions qui étaient pr qui étaient
considéré comme extrêmement critiques
dans dans le système des exigences qui
étaient attendu était précisé à l'annexe
du règlement de la consultation de la
proposition initiale les résultats des
essais des démonstrateurs initiaux qui
n'étaaiit pas engageant pour les
candidats ont été tels que l'État a
décidé de demander la fourniture d'un
nouveau démonstrateur dans le cadre de
la remise de l'ofre
finale je rajouterai que lors de la
remise de l'offre finale pour s'assurer
du bon seement des démonstrateurs l'État
a mis à disposition de chaque candidat
local sécurisé il a il a alors pu
installer ses équipements s'assurer du
bon fonctionnement de ceuxci avant de
laisser à la disposition de l'État pour
les essais chaque candidat a disposé de
conditions identiques pour
l'installation de son démonstrateur
local sécurisé électricité surveillance
temps d' installation etess de bon
fonctionnement et cetera la la
qualification de la performance globale
du système et la vérification du bon
fonctionnement lors de la montée en
charge ne faisait pas partie de ce
démonstrateur qui a donc porté
essentiellement sur la fonction de
collecte des éléments d'assiette de la
taxe donc en quelque sorte c'est un
prototype oui enfin en miniature
d'accord et il y a échelle
réduite d'accord je sa pas je sais pas
si quelqu'un encore des questions
technologiques peut-être avant de passer
à a sur la technique non moi je suis sur
le contrat plutôt crting ah Monsieur
crattinger
pardon merci madame la rapporteur madame
la Présidente moi je voudrais poser une
question donc Monsieur le Directeur
général des infrastructures des
transport et de la mer
euh une question enfin quelques
questions qui qui se regroupe dans un
chapitre voilà d'abord le système
français celui que qui a été adopté
est-il comme le souhaitent les
directives européennes
interopérabl avec les dispositifs mis en
œuvre euh dans les États qui nous
bordent en particulier dans le nord-est
de la France parce que c'est de là que
s'écoule le plus grand nombre des
véhicules routiers c'est un premier
élément de de
questions la la la 2è 2è question 2è
interrogation
euh bon la complexité est souvent
évoquée personnellement je ne vois
d'ailleurs pas très bien comment ça ne
serait pas complexe
mais cette complexité
justifiait-il justifiait tel
pardon le recours à
des disons
à à la procédure telle qu'elle a été
adoptée c'est-à-dire celle d'un PPP
est-ce que cette complexité
avéré justifie cette procédure de PPP ou
bien il y avait il d'autres chemins et
si oui
lesquels et quels étaient euh leurs
avantages ou leurs inconvénients et puis
dans la dans le même chapitre il y
avait-il un intérêt à à à séparer euh la
construction de l'exploitation d'un tel
système cette question monsieur le
Président
euh la première question sur
l'interopérabilité le principe est bien
effectivement contrairement au système
allemand où les systèmes de d'équipement
embarqués doivent être achetés au
prestataires enfin au au ppistes qui
gère le contrat et que le système puisse
être opéré avec des des équipements
embarqués qui appartiennent et qui sont
fournis par les différentes sociétés
habilité de télépayage donc le système
est bien prévu pour être interopérable
ça c'est la première réponse c'est
d'ailleurs une des un des des sujets que
la Commission européenne a regardé a
regardé de près dans tous nos
dispositifs s'assure que le le système
si les les sociétés habilité de TPH donc
voulait fournir des équipements
embarqués que ça soit une possibilité
sur
le la question du du
recours à des au PPP alors
euh c'est c'est effectivement la la
question alors quel est quelle était
l'alternative par rapport à quel les
autres formules
euh l'autre l'autre formule c'était de
passer un système en maîtrise d'ouvrage
public qui était effectivement un
système qu'on aurait pu qu'on aurait pu
envisager
euh mais effectivement ça paraissait
extrêmement compliqué et je ne suis pas
convaincu que
le je dirais que l'administration pas
seulement celle que je dir d'ailleurs
que l'administration était en
état de de de prévoir
effectivement une une consultation sur
un système aussi complexe avec du coup
l'obligation pour elle de s'assurer que
tous les interfaces étaient
bien comment dirais-je était bien
fonctionnel il y avait qu'un véritable
risque que s'il y avait des
dysfonctionnement ensuite on soit dans
une complexité de chercher les
responsabilités des uns et des autres
euh qui qui aurait été quasiment
impossible hein
euh je je veux pas citer les exemples
que je je connais bien dans dans le
bâtiment mais c'est certain qu'à partir
du moment où les les bâtiments euh euh
sont on a des bâtiments extrêmement
complexes à construire euh le fait
d'essayer de travailler en lot séparé
rend l'exercice particulièrement
compliqué ens suite de coordination et
cetera et je ne pense pas que en tout
cas dans mes équipes ou dans cell de la
desgddi nous avions les moyens humains
pour assurer cette coordination et ces
interfaces sauf à utiliser alors des des
armada de de bureau d'études pour nous
nous conseiller ce qui aurait été ce qui
aurait été compliqué euh je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il y a un pays je veux pas
je pense que c'est le le Pays-Bas qui
avait adopté cette logique
d'allotissement et qui effectivement
était arrivé effectivement quelque chose
d'impossible avec 200 agents et des
conseils divers pour mener le projet que
d'ailleurs entreetemps il a abandonné en
en février 2010 je ne veux pas non
plus citer des exemples que que queon
connaît dans dans notre pays mais euh je
je je crois que l'exemple de de la paye
du du ministère de la Défense
malheureusement montre aussi que il y a
quelques difficultés en gérer en
maîtrise d'ouvrage direct ce genre ce
genre de projet avec des interfaces des
interfaces multiples donc sur sur ce
recours au PPP je je je confirme que mon
l'analyse qu'on a faite l'analyse
d'ailleurs de de la map qui qui a été
produite justifie totalement la
procédure que l'on a que l'on a mise en
place et juste pour revenir sur
l'interopérabilité l'interopérabilité
c'est avec un certain nombre de pays
européens avec quel pays le système
choisi est-il réellement
interopérable
le le système encore prévoit que les ce
soit les les équipements c'est les
équipements embarqués et donc il y a
plusieurs sociétés habilité de
télépayage qui se sont mises dans le
dans le dans le système dans dans le
projet effectivement et qui propose
leurs propres équipements embarqués du
coup ce n'est pas celui qui est fourni
par ecomov qui est le seul qui est
disponible pour les euh pour les pour
les transporteurs oui mais justement euh
ma question précise elle est les
équipements embarqués aujourd'hui
fournis par ecomov ou par les les
sociétés de télépéage agréé sont
interopérable sur quelle géographie quel
territoire géographique avec quel pays
autrement dit ce qu'on est je vais
volontairement forcer le trit est-ce
qu'on est interopérable avec le Brésil
ou est-ce qu'on est interopérable avec
l'Italie d'accord ben ce sont les les
les les réseaux donc c'est la question
géographique que vous posez si je
comprends bience que je je cherchais la
liste que je connais pas par cœur mais
la liste des des sociétés de télépage
effectivement qui sont dans le dans le
projet donc les les réseaux sur lesquels
les équipements n'ont pas été choisis ni
par nous d'ailleurs ni par
eomove autant que je sache les SHT donc
avec lesquels on travaille sont
implantés sur quatre pays la France
l'Italie l'Espagne et il y en a un 4è la
Belgique je crois donc sur lequel
d'ailleurs il y a un projet de semblable
au l're qui est en train d'être
développé d'accord donc son quatre pays
que je peux citer d'accord et par
rapport où est acheté effectivement le
vrai sujet c'est que effffectivement les
transporteurs n'est pas n'est pas à
s'équiper de de 50 enfin j'agère de 28
s'il y a 28 pays qui mettent ce genre de
système de 28 équipements différents
pour traverser chaque pays et donc c'est
effectivement les SHT qui elles doivent
avoir un équipement embarqué et qui soit
interopérable dans plusieurs pays
d'accord et juste une autre question
estce que vous venez de parler du d'un
logiciel qui a posé quelques soucis à la
défense est-ce que justement l'une des
sociétés de la SAS ecomov n'est pas la
société qui a fourni Leod logiciel
madame madame la rapporteur je voudrais
pas rentrer dans le détail euh
effectivement sta est intervenu à un
moment dans le pour le citer hein est
intervenu dans le système du logiciel de
la défense je me permets je ne devrais
pas le faire devir des entend de votre
très haute assemblée de renvoyer à ce
qui est écrit dans le rapport de la
mission d'information de l'Assemblée sur
le sujet qui dit Queau contraire cri est
intervenu à un moment plutôt pour sauver
le projet qu'autre
chose le document de l'Assemblée
évidemment est
publique avant de donner la parole à à
michel Teston et et et Louis negre qui
l'ont demandé moi j'avais une question à
vous poser d'abord sur comment les
tarifs de l'écotaxe sont fixés euh je
sair comment vous les avez déterminé ces
tarifs est-ce que vous avez fixé un
produit total pour déterminer ensuite
des tarifs ou est-ce que vous avez
déduit le le le produit total après
avoir arrêté les tarifs ça c'est une
question qu'on a pas encore posé
vraiment ah c'est une excellente
question présidente
maiss elle est elle est importante
excellente euh je je j'aurais un peu
tendance à renvoyer la question
parlementaire dans je veux pas faire de
de mauvais esprit
euh le chiffre qui a été évoqué depuis
le début attendu de cette recette dans
les débats effectivement parlementaires
et quand le le dossier a été abordé sur
le plan politique hein euh moi j'ai
entendu parler vous tous vous avez
souvent entendu parler d'un chiffre qui
tournait autour d'un milliard d'euros
c'est c'était l'objectif que c'était
fixé le que m'avait indiqué le le
ministre à l'époque Jean-Louis borlau
c'était l'ordre de grandeur de ce qu'on
attendait de cette de cette éax et et
donc effectivement on a fait deux
calculs
euh on a fait un premier un premier
calcul euh qui était donc dans le
respect des normes et des obligations de
la Commission européenne de calculer le
taux plafond qu'il était possible
d'imposer euh à qui était possible
d'imposer au transporteurs puisque ce
tau plafond doit effectivement refléter
le coût d'usage de l'infrastructure on a
abouti à un chiffre mes collaborateurs
ont dû vous en parler ce t plafond lors
de C
centimes d'euros du du kilomètre
euh après donc on avait toute l'attitude
pour fixer ce taux
entre de taux plafond je dis bien
plond comis c'était la réisation non non
ça c'est le premier exercice de calcul
respect des règles
communautaires donc 16 centimes d' rou
du kilomètre on n'aurait pas pu en
l'état actuel du réseau des coûts
d'investissement des coûts d'entretien
et cetera ça aurait pu être délicat euh
au regard du respect de la directive
Eurovignette de fixer un coût supérieur
à 16 centimes d'euros du kilomètre alors
après effectivement les 12 centimes ou
les 13 centimes ont été calculés pour
remplir à peu près la commande qui était
de récupérer un donc vous me dites vous
me répondz que c'est le produit total
qui a été décidé sachant que quand même
vous avez décidé quand même des des de
des du du charge de la charge des des
camions on on a décidé 3 tonnes5 on
aurait pu déci 12 tonnes comme en
Allemagne vous avez quand même aussi
déterminé quand même le le réseau
taxable aussi alors c'est c'est la loi
qui a décidé c'est la oui en fait c'est
vos calcul quand même de votre ministère
alors attendez non sur le sur le
chiffrage que je viens de dire c'est
effectivement les calculs de notre
ministerè c'est c'est c'est tout à fait
clair c'est c'est important ce que vous
dites parce que si on a décidé du tarif
global aujourd'hui c'est difficile après
de dire que c'est cher les 232 millions
parce que c'est plus voilà on fixe pas
dire madame la Présidente
c'est que vous répondiez bien à cette
question ou non non je vous fais je vous
fais pas dire si d'abord al
effectivement le plafond 16 centimes euh
au-delà de ça je pense qu'il y avait des
des risques 16 centimes ou 16 centimes 5
je dirais pas au centimes près mais 16
centimes au-delà de ça effectivement il
y avait des vrais risques contentieux au
regard du respect de la directive
eurovgette c'est tout à fait clair donc
il fallait qu'on fixe un
chiffre qui soit inférieur à ce montant
je je me permets juste de faire une
petite allusion je reviendrai ensuite à
votre à votre question sur 3 tonn 5 12
tonn euh
si demain on décidait que les régions
devaient fixer individuellement leur
taux puisque j'entends j'entends dire ça
ici ou
là je dis bien si les région deent fixer
individuellement leur taux parce qu'il y
a d'autres formules que fixer
individuement Tau et si c'était ça
l'hypothèse il y aurait un vrai sujet
pour le coup on devrait refaire
travailler les ordinateurs parce que ce
taux devrait être calculé région par
région le plafond je dis bien le plafond
au regard de ce que je viens de dire par
rapport au directives européennes donc
ça c'est par rapport à votre question
donc sur le 12 centimes 13 centimes le
milliard d'euros la la deème question 3
ton5 12 tonnes au-delà de la boutade
effectivement sur le fait que ça a été
que ça a été voté comme ça euh le le
chiffre le le tonnage c'est les
orientations actuelles de la Commission
européenne qui incitent plutôt à mettre
le seuil à 3 ton5 mais on peut là aussi
dans toutes les discussion qu'il y a
c'est un sujet qui peut être ouvert euh
de de savoir si effectivement on devait
revenir un tonnage plus élevé comme se
minimum de taxation alors je donne la
parole à michel Teston d'abord qui l'a
demandé merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le le directeur général en
réponse à à la question posée par
crtin vous avez indiqué que la maîtrise
d'ouvrage donc publique aurait posé de
gros problèmes et que c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles elle n'a pas été
retenue moi je peux pas empêcher de
constater que euh on est passé de 320
millions d'euros à 580 millions d'euros
son les chiffres que vous venez de de
citer expressément et donc il y a eu un
écart très important par rapport à
l'évaluation initiale dès lors bien
évidemment il y a pas que l'aspect
gestion et les problèmes que ça pouvait
poser pour la puissance publique qui
devait être prise en compte il y a la
question également du coûte pour la
collectivité en général donc ma question
est très simple qui a pris la décision
de recourir au Partenariat Public Privé
est-ce que c'est vous est-ce que c'est
vous en lien avec d'autres directeur du
ministère oou est-ce que la décision a
été politique
ou
là le le choix donc a été
soumis la possibilité déjà de recourir à
un
PPP a été soumise au Conseil
d'État qui donc et donc sur ce planl
c'est le gouvernement qui pose des
questions
c'est le gouvernement qui pose les
questions au Conseil d'État et en posant
la question le gouvernement avait
clairement effectivement en tête que ce
soit une des solutions qui puisse être
qui puisse être retenue ensuite il y a
eu la phase de de
consultation c'est c'est évidemment une
décision du gouvernement qui a
surprosition des directions généralesin
j'assume
complètement la direction générale la
mienne la direction générale des douanes
et des droits indirects la direction du
le budget avait regardé ça aussi la
direction de la législation fiscale a
regardé ça aussi euh donc voilà c'est
c'est ça le processus qui a eu lieu et
la consultation a été faite évidemment
dans cette forme avec l'accord des des
ministres de tutelle et pourquoi avir
mis en place une une émission de
tarification spécifique au au contrat éc
taxes alors qu'il existe quand même un
département d'expertise des PPP au sein
de la Direction Générale alors c'est
étonnant ça qu'on a fait ça j'ai pas
très bien compris il y a pas tant que ça
de PPP de l'étage je crois que
actuellement ils en ont tr BPP à suivre
donc cette direction je pense qu'elle
est pas surchargée c'est je suis étonné
parce que après j'ai pas très bien
compris dans les auditions ce que
vraiment cette mission de la
tarification avait avait avait fait
voilà je pas la missionification parce
que je pense qu'elle est vous les avez
auditionné je pense que c'est la
missionification qui a piloté tout le
projet donc
c'est je parle pas du département PPP
attendez je donc pour revenirus c'est
pourquoi la création
alors pourquoi la création de cette
mission c'est parce que il s'agissait
d'un projet extrêmement spécifique comme
vous l'avez fait remarquer qui en plus a
nécessité de faire travailler deux
directions générales
ensemble puisque le projet il a été
conduit complètement la plupart des
notes qui ont été faites sur le sujet
ont été Cigné entre moi-même et mon
collègue mon collègue des douanes alors
il y a cert un département d'expertise
sur les PPP dans ma direction générale
dont vous avez auditionné le le
responsable
et je voudrais juste faire un tout petit
un tout petit décrochage par rapport à
ça le le le Conseil Général de
l'environnement et du dévelppement
durable a expertisé le système et la
manière dont les PPP étaient géré pour
l'ensemble du ministère ils ont il y a
un rapport qui a été remis que
évidemment nous tenons à votre
disposition sur le sur le sujet et a
considérer qu'on avait une opisation qui
était très convenable il a même proposé
allant dans un sens qui est totalement
euh comment dirais-je qui qui n'est pas
celui que vous suggérez qui est qui
serait au contraire que cette mission
n'intervienne qu'en conseil des quen
conseille des services qui gèent des PPP
donc elle est aucune mission
opérationnelle j'ai fait le choix qui a
été retenu par les arrêtés successifs
d'organisation du du ministère j'ai fait
le choix que ce département de PPP
traite effectivement les PPP routiers
qui sont ceux dans lesquels ceux qui
sont traités par la direction son dans
lequel est rattaché ce département PPP
et les autres PPP sont traités par des
des services différents donc la mission
tarification qui a été mise en place
mais je vous répondrai précisément par
écrit hein sur toutes ces motivations la
mission de tarification qui a été
spécifiquement mise en place pour la
complexité du projet et pour être
clairement complètement en binôme avec
la Direction générale des droits et des
douanes et des droits indirect avec un
directeur que nous avons choisi d' comme
un accord Antoine mocor qui est qui est
derrière moi assisteré en fait de de
deux S adjoints je dirais un à la DGITM
Olivier coi et l'autre à la DG DDI qui
est Anne coril donc l'idée était
vraiment effectivement d'avoir une
mission très très spécifique là-dessus
qui par contre a eu recours évidemment à
des expertises diverses dans la dans le
ministère quand il en a quand il en a eu
besoin mais et et et encore une fois
donc on est on est plutôt par rapport à
la question que vous posez à un peu à
l'inverse de parce qu'on pourrait
imaginer
aussi à l'inverse de ce que le conseil
général avait nous avait suggéré euh on
pourrait effectivement imaginer que donc
formule où le département PPP ne
traiterait aucun PPP et une autre au
contraire où il traiterait tous les PPP
du ministère mais bon j'ai considéré à
tort ou à raison enfin je pense que
encore une fois le projet est en ce
qu'id on est quand même arrivé à le à le
à conduire me semble-t-il correctement
je je c'est appréciation personnelle sur
ce sujet
euh de de confier tous les tous les tous
les PPPs département aurait sans doute
gonfler un peu trop fort et et sur un
sujet pareil aurait rendu difficile la
production du du dispositif mais je
répondrai par écrit hein sur ce point y
compris sur les décisions qui ont qui
ont confié le pilotage et cetera puisil
y a des il y a des vrais vrais sujets
oui pardonnez-moi d'insister et de de
poser et de reposer des des questions
mais on est en commission d'enquête donc
on aime bien avoir les réponses y
compris par plusieurs par plusieurs bi
bien sûr
euh sur ce PPP chaque fois qu'on pose la
question de la pertinence du PPP on nous
répond le Conseil d'État a dit que mais
le Conseil d'État n'a jamais dit que
c'était la meilleure des solutions il a
simplement considérer qu'il était
effectivement possible de passer un PPP
y compris pour tous les aspects fiscaux
sous réserve de certaines conditions et
cetera et cetera donc nous répondre que
le Conseil d'État a dit que il me
semble-t-il n'est pas la réponse à la
question la question précise elle est un
PPP pouvait-il ou devait-il être la
meilleure des solutions
quel que soit l'endroit où on mettait le
curseur donc aujourd'hui le curseur les
douanes nous l'ont clairement explicité
c'est le recouvrement forcé c'est de
notre compétence et tout le reste et la
compétence du du privé est-ce que
c'était vraiment la meilleure solution
ou est-ce que c'était la solution à la
fois la plus simple est-ce que c'était
la solution qui permettait de garantir
le meilleur euh le meilleur
fonctionnement et investissement des
finances publiques est-ce que c'était la
solution qui permettait le meilleur
contrôle est-ce que c'était la solution
qui permettait d'aller le plus vite bah
écoutez j'ai essayé de répondre à cette
question euh j'ai probablement pas été
assez clair mais je ma réponse a dit oui
je je j'ai essayé de donner les les
explications à ma connaissance
d'ailleurs c'est des c'est des systèmes
extrêmement proches en plus qui ont été
retenus retenus à l'étranger euh voilà
je peux je pas vous en dire plus enfin
je vous dis la complexité du système
l'intégration du système euh le fait
effectivement de la la difficulté
d'avoir à gérer des interfaces entre des
des intervenants en divers l'absence de
de compétences suffisamment nombreuses
et qualifiées au sein de de nos
structure faisait que c démarche qui
apparaissait la plus la plus
logique alors Monsieur demandé la parle
y a une des questions de Monsieur Teston
au j'ai pas répondu ah alors fa le faire
pardonnez-moi bon je m'excuse non non
c'est moi qui
est bon c'est ça vous va ok alors c'est
bien Madame la Présidente Monsieur le
directeur général je vais aborder cette
question vous voyez depuis une
demi-heure ça tourne autour de la mop ou
du PPP finalement on se demande pourquoi
quelle mouche vous a piqué de prendre un
PPP on voit bien la difficulté d'aborder
ce sujet alors moi je vais le prendre
d'une manière un peu différente j'ai
quelques souvenirs de la toltax qui
s'est installée en Allemagne et ma
question est donc ma première question
elle est la suivante qu'on fait les
autres pays européens qui se sont
retrouvés dans la même situation
d'établir une écotaxe est-ce qu'ils sont
passés par la mop ou est-ce qu'ils sont
passés par des PPP ma réponse je là
aussi je parle scerement donc je veux
pas dire des choses dont je ne suis pas
sûr il y a au moins deux pays où je suis
tout à fait sûr que c'est passé en PPP
c'est la l'Allemagne et la République
tchèque
la slovaie
slovie de pays don sur lesquel je suis
sûr et autant que je sache pareil je
veux pas dire de bêtis je crois que la
Belgique est en train de s'engager sur
le même principe bien donc inversement
est-ce que vous connaissez des pays
européens qui sont passés en maîtrise
d'ouvrage public pour mettre en
place il y a peut-être
un un qui n'est pas dans l'Union
européenne qui la Suisse
donc avec un système effectivement
notamment sur les POS lourds qui est
spécifique et qui est plus ancien je
crois des plus ancien donc ça serait
intéressant de savoir je le dis à la
commission d'enquête pourquoi pourquoi
les autres pays ont pris un système qui
n'est pas la mop bon la deuxème question
que je pose au niveau
des industriel et des innovations
technologique du système mise en place
là encore pour être allé sur place on a
cru comprendre que cétait système très
innovant bon l'interrabilité en
particulier mon oui B j'ai vu que nous
avions des entreprises françaises
là-dedans pas que les Italiens des
entreprises françaises comme Thalès et
cetera qui sont des entreprises de
pointe est-ce qu'on peut imaginer que
cela pouvait avoir un effet sur la
capacité d'exportation deain d'un
produit français
innovant parce que ça a joué à un
quelconque
est- querie françiseit en TI gloire
voilà alors il y a des dans dans
l'ensemble du système il y a des SAET
déjà qui sont pour certaines françaises
donc effectivement qui participaient à
un système en France et qui du coup
pouvait opérer dans d'autres
pays vous avez cité thalè je suis
convaincu que
si je suis convaincu donc c'est un
sentiment que je donne c'est pas une
affirmation j'ai j'ai tendance à penser
que si euh il n'était pas arrivé ce qui
est arrivé à notre taxe en France Talès
aurait pu être en bonne position pour
répondre en Belgique et donc exporter la
technologie en Belgique 3è et dernière
question c'est une question j'allais
dire sinon d'ambiance du moins de fond
si c'était à refaire Monsieur le
Directeur Général referiez-vous la même
chose et auriez-vous le même choix à
préconiser alors ma réponse A est claire
c'est
oui j'ai aucun étatâ là-dessus je ferai
juste un commentaire parce que il y a un
moment où sur le plan personnel puisque
là vous PZ une question très
personnelle je me permet juste de faire
un commentaire vous avez sans doute en
tout cas pour certaines ou certains
d'entre vous lu des déclarations
récentes du vice-président du Conseil
d'État qui est not chef notre chef à
tous fonctionnaires
qui incite les fonctionnaires à prendre
des
risques et qui dit que c'est pas parce
que il y a
société surveille de plus en plus j'ai
même son son interview là je je l'ai lu
juste avant de venir qui dit que c'est
pas parce que la société demande de plus
en plus de rendre des comptes qu'il faut
que les fonctionnaires soient attentifs
et ne prennent pas de risque donc je
pense à titre personnel qu'effectivement
moi-même mon équipe nous avons pris des
risques en conduisant ce projet c'est
tout à fait clair je les assume
complètement et encore une fois je vous
dis que s'il fallait les refaire je
referaiis de la même
façon alors éc do a demandé la parole et
bien merci madame la
Présidente juste une incidence je
pensais comme le Conseil d'État
président du Conseil d'État ou le
vice-président du Conseil d'État a dit
qu'il fallait prendre des risques
j'espère qu'il en prendra dans le cadre
du découpage des cantons et qu'il sera
regarder ça avec beaucoup d'atention
j'ai assez envie de vous lire c'est vous
qui m'avez j'ai assez envie de vous lire
si vous
très courte la la partie de son
interview qui parle de ça ça ça m'a
beaucoup interpellé je vous je vous le
cache pas euh la prudence et la
prévoillance sont deux qualités
nécessaires dans la prise de décision
publique je je pense je pense assumer ça
mais doivent pas être dévoyé au point de
devenir de la réticence et de la
frilosité voire de la crainte d'agir la
conduite des politiques publiques
implique que des risques soient pris et
assumé et or aujourd'hui alors que les
méthodes de management reposent sur la
performance et l'évaluation se
développent paradoxalement et de manière
préoccupante des comportements de plus
en plus précautionneux la société
française a de plus en plus soif de
justice et cetera mais cela ne doit pas
être inf d'inhibition les décideurs
publics doivent accepter et dépasser ces
contraintes bien merci je de cette
interview j'ai pas eu le temps de la
prendre par cœur mais je le regarderai
parce que je lu ressortirai à l'occasion
je bah vous me le passez al ça peut
m'être utile bien donc merci ceci étant
bon on a réglé nos affaires personnelles
on va passer peut-être au au revenir au
sujet d'abord pour vous dire que moi je
considère que le partenariat public
privé a été mis en place comme un un un
outil qui doit permettre effectivement
d'apporter des réponses dans certains
cas et quand on prend la la définition
de l'objet du marché qui a été passé je
trouve que c'est tout à fait dans le
cadre des PPP enfin bref chacun a sa
vision moi je pense que si j'avais été
si j'ai un jour j'avais pu être
directeur général des routes je pense
que d'abord j'aurais mieux réglé mes
problèmes routiers chez moi donc et puis
ensuite j'aurais probablement passé la
la même ceci étant dans dans les délais
moi je
m'interroge parce que on parle toujours
du délai euh à laquelle auquel pardon
devait être
livré le processus définitif qui était
au mois de septembre au mois de juillet
ou au mois de d'août 2013 je crois le 20
juillet 2013 20 juillet 2013 mais je
voilà mais je me souviens d'un certain
nombre d'auditions qu'on a pu avoir
avant euh dans le cadre d'un certain
nombre de réflexions du transfert des
routes et puis au-delà dans la cadre de
la mise en place de ce système d'une
écotaxe et et je me souviens qu'on avait
évoqué des mises en œuvre plus précoces
si je dire tout à fait monsieur
président donc donc ce serait peut-être
intéressant quand même de resituer dans
le cadre par rapport à la loi origine
parce que moi je me souviens que dans
certains budgets dès 2012 me semble-t-il
on marquait déjà ou on inscrivait déjà
des recettes potentielles donc ça n'est
pas qu'à partir de juillet 2013 donc il
y a il y a ce point particulier puis de
voir la date réelle d'entrée en œufre
qui était prévu au au mois de de juillet
alors effectivement on vous a posé les
questions les retards du à ecomu et
cetera je pense aussi que qu'à l'époque
où on en est maintenant et par rapport à
la future mise en œuvre tous les retards
ne seront pas d à à écomov entre la mise
en œuvre réelle et
l'application de la FA facturation et la
date d'aujourd'hui puisque si ecomov
n'est pas encore tout à fait prêt ou est
prêt aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y en a
encore pour un certain nombre de mois
donc il y aura des responsabilités qui
probablement vont être de plus en plus
partagé euh
ensuite tout à l'heure j'ai entendu pour
ça j'aimerais pas qu' qu'il y ait un
faux une fausse information qui circule
on dit les les les taux pourrai être
fixés au niveau des régions en non non
mais c'est des bruits qui courent je les
ai lu comme vous je les ai lu comme vous
mais je je rectifie parce que enfin je
rectifie je précise parce que à ma
connaissance c'est pas les régions qui
sont responsables des routes sur les le
terrain et si les régions se mettent à
déterminer des tarifs au niveau régional
alors que la propriété des routes n'est
pas la leure et qu'elle des très
variable selon les territoires ça peut
poser un certain nombre de problèmes
donc je me permets cette incidence tant
que une nouvelle loi n'est pas votée sur
voilà les nouvelles régions ou alors
cela sous-entend que on fait disparaître
les départements et que les régions
reprennent les routes donc c'est pas
neutre tous les débats qui ont lieu
actuellement et je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention à ces prérequis qui
m'inquiète qui m'inquièteent quelque peu
ensuite tout à l'heure bon j'ai entendu
le coût pour la collectivité je vais
rappeler quand même que le rapport enfin
le rapport financier est prévu bon coût
de 1illard millions en gros hein enfin
coût facturation d'un milillard 200
millions et puis rapport net pour l'état
de 900 millions à peu près euh à peu
près un peu moins qu'U de ce qui prévu
pour les collectivités ou oui enfin il y
avait 100 oui voilà bon enfin don donc
c'est quand même un bon rapport
financier moi je sais pas si on me
donnait l'autorisation de le faire un
tel rapport financier je plongerai
dessus rapidement donc c'est pas si
mauvais que ça comme rapport financier
c'est vrai que ça coûte cher à percevoir
mais investir 200 millions pour en
récupérer 800 ou 900 c'est quand même
pas une si mauvaise si mauvaise affaire
c'est pas une critique c'est une
constatation moi j'en suis ravi euh pour
ma part après dernier point euh et là
c'est une question que je pose
systématiquement bon vous l'avez vu dans
dans dans les coûts enfin dans les
recettes plus exactement les
collectivités doivent percevoir 100 à
160 millions enfin ça dépend euh du
trafic tout ça un certain nombre de
choses donc les collectivités euh attend
avec une certaine impatience qu'il a des
décisions qui soient prises au niveau de
l'État dès queekov sera totalement
conforme pour que les recettes
arrivent et et pensez-vous d'abord
est-ce que vous avez une idée de la date
bon ça c'est peut-être lire dans le mar
de café parce que ça dépendra plus de
décisions politiqu probablement que que
des décisions administratives ensuite
les collectivités qui attendaient des
recettes sont tel endroit d'attendre des
arriérés de recettes donc c'est un sujet
important sur lesquels bien sûr les les
collectivités qui inscrivent leur des
recettes importantes dans leur budget
dans des périodes
difficiles iront certainement demander
des comptes à un moment donné parce que
ça sera de la responsabilité de l'État
d'avoir décidé peut-être é laisser la
suspension un tout petit peu de côté je
préféris que d'abord on termine sur
toutes les
it lapension consquence un tout petit
peu à la fin pour qu'on soit parce qu'on
est tous à avoir beaucoup de questions
sur la suspension donc on reviendra
là-dessus sur les retard je crois que
c'est important que vous puissiez
répondre à ce stade je vais je vais
répondre à deux des questions de
Monsieur effectivement j'allais proposer
effectivement d'essayer de regrouper
parce que en plus c sujets qui sont pour
partie pas du tout dans ma main vous
vous en doutez sur la suspension
euh sur la date donc effectivement dans
une version optimiste dans le cadre du
Grenel de
l'environnement et j'en ai fait j'ai
fait allusion à l'incitation très forte
et au volontarisme du ministre de de
l'époque sur le fait que ça évite on
avait imaginé que ça pue entrer en
service effectivement fin 2011 début
2012 c'était ça le le scénario alors il
y a eu deux deux élément par rapport à
deux éléments qui ont fait que ce
calendrier a été a été décalé le premier
c'est qu'effectivement les procédures
euh comme vous avez pu le voir ont été
assez assez compliquées la mise au point
effectivement du du cahier des charges
les échanges avec les uns et les autres
pour être sûr qu'on ne faisait pas
fausse route
le le la procédure de dialogue
compétitif et cetera tout ça a fait que
je dirais que par rapport au 31 janvier
2012 et au au 1er janvier 2012 je dirais
comme date de référence j'assume
parfaitement qu'il est eu effectivement
sur le plan technique dans la gestion de
la préparation du
dossier un délai d'à peu près je dirais
un an un an supplémentaire voilàu
presque sur le plan technique par
rapport encore une fois au volontarisme
qui était affiché je n'ai plus en tête
les délais qui ont été qui ont qui ont
existé en Allemagne pour la mise en
place du dispositif mais avec ces dél là
et par rapport au au premier V du
dispositif donc en loi de finances 2009
je pense que si euh on avait respecté
encore une fois 2012 courant ou fin 2012
ça aur été très très très bien et puis
on a perdu aussi euh et là par contre
évidemment je je n'assume pas même si ça
fait partie du du projet on a perdu
effectivement de l'ordre de 6 mois avec
le contentieux au Conseil d'État sur le
le classement et le du contrat qui a
pris je dirais toute la première moitié
euh de l'année 2011 puisque le recours a
eu lieu début 2011 et qu'il a été jugé
par le Conseil d'État fin fin 2011 voilà
à peu près euh encore une fois les dates
qui étaient affichées au début euh était
sans doute très volontariste mais le
ministre encore une fois insistait pour
que ça avance la deuxème question par
rapport au cout moi je ne je ne diraiis
pas grand-chose par rapport à ce que
vous avez dit madame la Présidente il a
fait une allusion c'est
euh de faire des calculs en pourcentage
effectivement c'est un peu compliqué
dans la mesure où euh on fixe un taux
donc à la limite si demain
euh on décidait de fixer un taux à la
moitié de ceci qui est actuellement le
coût en proportion deviendrait
absolument faramineux à l'inverse si on
allait au plafond en pourcentage il
serait plus faible puis je dirais
euh je dirais aussi là aussi parce que
il faut comparer évidemment avec les
coûts des pays étrangers ça on a des des
éléments qui sont à votre à votre
disposition sur le coût de de gestion
des dispositifs qui encore une fois ne
sont pas interopérables et puis sans non
plus vouloir jeter la quelque pierre que
ce soit à qui que ce soit euh il y a un
l'autre exemple dans notre pays de de
gestion d'un système beaucoup plus
simple que celui-là qui est le système
de gestion des radars
automatisés je crois que par rapport à
la recette il est plus élevé que le que
le coût de de notre projet qui est quand
même alors qu'il n'y a pas de système de
suivi satellitaire et donc il est dans
le principe plus simple mais en disant
ça je dis bien que je jette pas la
pierre parce que tant ce projet j'ai
pris soin de le dire dans l'introduction
que le sujet des des radars automatisés
contrôle automatisé ce sont pas des
sujets qui sont fait uniquement pour
récupérer de l'argent le radar
automatisé c'est pour la sécurité
routière et et donc que c'est un coût
qui soit supérieur à un coût de
perception d'une taxe je dirais entre
guillemets ordinaire et paraît tout à
fait justifié et il en est de même pour
ce projet il y a il y a effectivement la
volonté de percevoir une taxe mais il y
a aussi une volonté d'opérer du du
report modal d'améliorer les chaînes
logistiques et ça ça ça a un cût il y a
aussi une volonté de faire payer les
transporteurs étrangers qui sont en
transit dans autre pays et tout ça un
coût donc de dire que c'est un impôt qui
coûte scandaleusement cher parce que il
est pas à 2 % du coût de person
perception voilà il y a un exemple qui
sont les amendes de radar c'est pas un
impôt mais c'est la perception
effectivement de d'amende où il y a une
volonté politique de faire un projet et
de d'améliorer la sécurité routière ça
un coup il y a notre projet aussi qui
pour ces raisons euh est plus cher
effectivement que la que la système de
perception d'une taxe entre guillemets
ordinaire et c'est d'ailleurs le choix
qui a été quand même fait de par
d'autres pays donc ça doit malgré tout
pas être si idau que ça avant que je
donne la parole à Monsieur grigon qui a
demandé pour rester sur les retards
quand même est-ce que vous pourriez nous
dire alors vraiment très directement
est-ce que vous estimez que l'État a une
part de responsabilité dans les deux
premiers reports de la taxe poiss lourd
on n'est pas encore dans dans la
suspension mais le 20 juillet on on
n'est pas prêt à priori le 1er octobre
on n'est pas prêt à priori est-ce que
sur ces deux premières dates il y a une
responsabilité de l'État ou si c'est
uniquement une responsabilité de Comou
alors je je considère et pour en avoir
parlé avec mes mes services qui sont
derrière et pour avoir suivi un certain
nombre de de comités de pilotage du proj
projet je considère que dans un que il
n'y a pas de responsabilité de l'État ou
dans le dans ses retards que c'est une
position que je défendrais si par
malheur demain il y avait un contentieux
sur ce sujet alors ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on gagnera parce que je pense que
Comou aura des arguments à nous à nous
opposer ce n'est évidemment pas la
position des comov sur ce retard de de 6
mois mais je pense que de plaider que le
retard est imputable entièrement
àcomove et et aujourd'hui en tout cas
l'option que je privilégierai d'accord
alors on je ne vous dis pas que je
gagnerai je ne vous dis pas que que
l'État gagnera la suspension on en
parlera après dis pas que l'État
gagnerit mais je dis que c'est la
position je cons précisément sur les
retards làdessus sur ces deux points je
je vous dis clairement que c'est la
position que je défendrai si demain il y
avait un contenus à défendre sur ce
point précis mais sans être sûr de le
gagner comme tout contentieux alors
monsieur grigon a demandé la parole et
après ce sera monsieur crattinger qui
l'a redemandé merci madame la Présidente
on tourne beaucoup autour du pot entre
les 350 et les 630 millions
alors moi j'ai une question à poser à
Monsieur le Directeur et s'il peut me
répondre à son âme et conscience on est
dans ce cas-là avec un sujet très
complexe où l'État n'assurait que la
maîtrise d'ouvrage du
projet ma question est si on était allé
plus loin comme le réclame certains avec
l'État qui assume la maîtrise d'œuvre en
s'entourant de tous les conseils qu'il
faut et tous les problèmes que vous avez
évoqué que cela suppose de de choses à
régler en entre les uns et les autres
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas sans jeter
la pierre à personne sur le premier
chiffre parce que je sais combien c'est
complexe que cette fois-ci le dérapage
aurait été catastrophique bon ce que je
veux dire je peux pas l'assurer je peux
pas l'assurer mais je pense
qu'effectivement de ce point de vue-là
il aurait peut-être pas été pour
répondre précisément à votre question je
fais allusion au bâtim ne compte pas la
somme des dépenses qu' alors il y a
évidemment toutes les dépenses de
personnel qu'il a fallu recruter mettre
en place de bureau d'étude et cetera
mais euh pour avoir là encore faire des
références à des sujets plus simples que
je maîtrise plus pour les avoir pratiqué
très en direct qui sont des sujets de
bâtiment on peut avoir quand on fait ce
genre de chose en l'eau en l'eau
séparé des offres qui dans un premier
temps sont assez alléchantes et quand on
fait calcul de l'eau par l'eau plutôt
avoir des résultats positifs mais c'est
ensuite dans les sujets d'exécution
effectivement et de problème de
responsabilité des uns et des autres et
d'Inter face l'on peut avoir des
dérapages donc il est pas impossible que
le résultat d'un dépouillement dans un
premier temps été du du même ordre de
grandeur qu'ensuite la gestion du
contrat pour enfin des contrats pour le
coup parce qu'il y aurait eu une
multitude de contrats aurait été
beaucoup plus compliqué j'ai pas fini
madame excusez-moi je non non mais c'est
une d'accord je continue c'est pas grave
bon j'ai les mêmes interrogations que
Monsieur Delinger on en parlera après
mais enfin pour mon département c'est un
ah j'ai pas répondu à la question de
Monsieur deier mais oui oui pour mon
département non monsieur mon deig je je
je monsieur grigon monsieur deig je suis
désolé euh je douter que le sujet alors
la date probable on en parlera tout à
l'heure comme su présent le le manque a
gagné les manque à gagné je suis désolé
vous doutez que c'est pas un élément
auquel je peux répondre personnellement
c'est un sujet que vous allez poser sur
le plan politique j'imagine monsieur le
sénateur bon alors je je pose pas la
question mais j'indique quand même
monsieur le directeur ça fait un million
d'euros en moins dans le département du
barrain et ça fait encore plus puisqueon
voulait être expérimentateur et qu'on a
pas pu avoir la petite plusvalue bien
mais j'ai une question de fond encore
parce que là je m'interroge ce qui nous
pourrit la vie avec ce système c'est les
3 tonnes 5 si on passait à 12 tonnes
quel serait le manque à gagner ou quel
serait le prix à mettre vous savez
peut-être pas aujourd'hui mais quel
serait le prix à mettre au lieu des 12
ou je sais plus combien de centime sans
aller jusqu'à 16 peut-être parce que ça
nous simplifierait vraiment la tâche en
a trans de proité j' des meilleurs on
conna tous le problème alors je vais je
vais essayer de répondre à votre
question sur les deux aspects monsieur
sénateur le premier aspect c'est si donc
il va fallo faire une règle de TR que
j'ai pas faite dans ma tête en tout cas
le le le chiffrage que que l'on a encore
une fois là sont les études de trafic du
du jour c'est que si on passait à 12
tonnes le manque à gagn de recett serait
de l'ordre je dis bien de 200 millions
d'euros euh donc en faisant la règle de
3 il faudrait passer probablement un
chiffre de l'ordre de 15 centimes si on
veut avoir la même recette ce qui est un
postulat
euh voilà ça doit être ça le calcul je
je le fais de tête ça doit être de
passer eu de passer à 14 ou 15 centimes
pour avoir la même recette alors par
contre par contre euh il y a un deuxième
volet à votre question que vous n'avez
pas que vous n'avez pas soulevé mais qui
qu'il faut bien évoquer euh
ce choix fait changer le système
technologique au moins des équipements
de contrôle fixe donc les fameux porties
puisque les porties qui ont
effectivement été conçus par thaless
sont fait pour reconnaître des des
masses de autour de 3
T5 pouvez nous dire quel est le coût
unitaire d'un portique parce que c'est
une question qui est posé c'est l' du
million c'est l' du million d'euros
million d'euros portique oui c'eston les
gros portiques hein c'est bien ça le
l'ordre de grandeur
euh bon si on doit parler plus des
portiques je parlerai plus des portiques
aussi euh donc donc effectivement il y a
euh alors làdedans il y a évidemment
l'aspect matériel métallique et il y a
évidemment aussi enfin ce qui est
coûteux c'est les systèmes de
reconnaissance de forme et c'est en ça
qu'il a une technologie euh
effectivement hyper pointue de Talès euh
donc il faudrait discuter avec euh il
faudrait discuter avec ecomove euh pour
voir dans quelle euh dans quelle mesure
effectivement il
et à quel coup parce que qui puisse le
faire je n'ai aucun doute sur le sujet à
quel coup ils peuvent proposer de faire
cette transformation et il faudra aussi
discuter avec les douanes si je peux me
permettre Monsieur le Directeur parce
que les douanes nous ont dit que si on
s'il fallait que on bouge quelque chose
bah il fallait revoir tout
l'environnement administratif des
arrêtés des décrets et cetera et qu' en
avait pour qu à 5 Mo avant que ça soit
opérationnel je je je vous dis ce qu'on
a vu entenduition j'ai j'ai j'ai ça je
dirais que c'est la c'est ouais mais ça
va
dans le cû aussi c'est les sujets
internes administration mais de toute
façon bon on parlera tout à l'heure de
la suspension et R déémarrage éventuel
délais pour un redémarrage éventuel
parce que je doute pas que vous poserez
cette question
euh entre le top départ et le jour où ça
peut fonctionner il y a effectivement
tout l'environnement administratif mais
je faisais ça on va revenir après
surension je faisais sous mon chapeau
euh par contre effectivement le le sujet
technologique il est là il il y a un
vrai sujet technologique malgré tout
mais qui est sur mon table je suppose
j'en ai pas parlé en détail avec Tales
euh je pense que la réponse la réponse
oui c'est faisable sur ce planl et mais
le sujet c'est à quel cûp surtout alors
dans le contexte compliqué dans lequel
on est dans la gestion du contrat avecou
vous vous en doutez d'accord monsieur
craattinger et ensuite Roland
ris marche ou merci déjà pour rappeler
que il y a 5500 même un peu plus je
crois kilomètr de routes départementales
qui sont taxables Monsieur le Directeur
je crois que c'est à peu près ça oui
c'est bien ça Mons et que c'est c'est en
c'est en application du texte de la loi
qui a été adopté au Parlement et et donc
c'est c'est c'est ce réseau taxable il
appartient principalement à l'état et de
façon secondaire au département il y a
très peu de voies communales qui sont
taxées il y a le périfque de strasour ou
a très peu j'ai dit très peu je par s
contrôle de Monsieur et donc bon ça
c'est pour le décorum c'est pas ma
question mais il faudra quand même
discuter si enfin si un jour il y avait
une des des des un comment dire un barê
qui ne soit pas national avec ceux qui
sont concernés quoi faudrait quand même
éviter de de confier la mission à ceux
qui ne le sont pas bon moi je je je
partage he le le le point de vue de
exprimé tout à l'heure par Éric deiger
euh et en même temps je je voudrais
poser à Monsieur le Directeur une
question assez directe quoi hein
euh bon il y a eu des retards il y a eu
et cetera moi j'ai j'ai beaucoup suivi
ce dossier donc je je je comprends tout
ça mais j'ai envie de lui poser une
question très directe bon tout au long
de ce de ce dossier qui maintenant a
vécu des périodes sous deux majorités
différentes donc sous deux gouvernements
différents la commande
politique a-t-elle toujours été claire
et suffisante je
dirais suffisamment précise suffisamment
forte suffisamment rapide quand elle
devait trancher hein sinon dans quel
domaine dans quel cas dans quelle
situation ça pas été suffisant parce que
ces retards ils ont alors des causes
administrativ mais n'ont-ils ou des
causes techniques mais n'ont-ils que des
causes administratives et techniques
hein et euh il y a eu visiblement une
sous-évaluation enfin tout du moins moi
je le ressens comme ça au départ des
contraintes et des délais
indispensables bon alors après dans
l'euphorie des fois on annonce des
choses pour demain matin et ça se
produit un peu plus tard hein mais et
donc est-ce que aujourd'hui bon on en
est c'est l'arrêt enfin je l'espère
provisoire de de de cette démarche de
taxep lourd que j'espère provisoire
personnellement bon c'est autre chose
qui s'est passé que le le la la disons
la la réalisation du de l'équipement qui
qui permet de la collecter hein et du
suivi et du contrôle c'est autre chose
mais dans cette partie même de depuis la
décision ici même au
Parlement jusqu'au mois d'octobre début
octobre on enregistrait les
pl0000 donc dans cette phase là est-ce
que voilà est-ce que sur cette phase là
vous pouvez répondre à ma question
est-ce que c'était clair suffisant tout
le temps et qu' y avait pas de problème
estce que il y a quand même eu moi je je
prends un exemple précis
quoi le le texte qui avait été qui est
paru d'ailleurs à une date bon qui est
facile à retenir le 6 mai 2012
concernant la récupération sur voilà
hein honnêtement moi quand je l'ai j'ai
essayé de le lire j'ai imaginé
immédiatement les difficultés que
pourrait avoir un un petit transporteur
avec avec un ou deux ou trois camions
comment il allait faire ça le dimanche
au lieu de regarder la télé ou d'aller
se promener quoi hein donc bon alors ça
on a refait un truc après et cetera
d'après vous qu'est-ce qui fait
que on est je dis pas perdu mais qu'on
est consommé tout ce temps voilà je ve
pas dire perdu parce que c'est jamais
perdu sur la gestion puisque vous me
posz une question monsieur le Président
je reviens pas sur le réseau local
taxable je crois que on
a mes collaborateurs ont dû donner des
exp sur ce raisau moi j'avais j'avais
trouvé que ça s'était très bien passé la
discussiondessus on a appliqué la loi
certain la petite marche
d'interprétation qu'elle laissait sur le
Conseil d'État a arbitré au bout donc on
a discuté département par département et
on est arrivé à un consensus dans la
quasi totalité des départements Conseil
d'État a fixé oui donc je reviens pas
sur ce sur ce sujet je pense qu'au
contraire enfin je je suis convaincu
qu'il a été géré du du mieux possible
effectivement cont tenu de la manière
dont la loi était rédigée et des des
processus qui ont été mis en place de de
discussion département par département
encore c'était un travail assez
astronomique que de regarder quels
étaient les effets de report parce que
c'était bien ce que prévit la loi que le
réseau local taxable devait être
essentiellement celui sur lequel il y
aurait des effets de report liés soit à
l'écotax soit existant déjà lié au
système autoroutier donc on a beaucoup
travaillé sur ce sujet et je crois
effectivement qu'on est arrivé à un
compromis dans le cadre encore une fois
du du respect de la loi qui avait été
voté par le le Parlement alors vous me
posez une question qui est si je peux la
résumer je pense en un mot monsieur le
président
qui est celle est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu'il a eu des retards qui a
été provoqué par une gestion politique
du dossier c'est c'est c'est pas ça j'ai
mal compris parce que
c'est y a des arbitrages politiques qui
doivent arriver de façon très honnête je
ne mets pas temp si on les donne le
lendemain matin de la question posée on
perd pas de temps si on les donne 6 mois
après on perd 6 mois je je ne peux que
répéter ce que que ce que j'ai j'ai dit
dans mon petit prop interocutif euh j'ai
toujours eu une pression politique forte
pour que le dossier avance et le décret
le le décret que vous je n'ai jamais eu
pour le coup d'aucun de mes patrons
ministre ou secrétaire d'État euh je
pense que les douanes je devrais pas le
dire à leur place n'ont pas eu non plus
de message dans dans un sens différent
je n'ai jamais eu de message me disant
qu'il fallait lever de pied ou ralentir
ça c'est je suis tout à fait formel
euh juste une explication puisque c'est
un texte réglementaire et donc
l'administration l'a préparé et en porte
une part de responsabilité sur le décret
que vous évoquez du 6 mai 2012 avec
certes toutes ces
imperfections je
pense mais là pour le coup ce sont les
ministres qui digné qui vous le diraiit
peut-être mieux que moi enfin mon
analyse personnelle encore une fois donc
un peu compliqué quand on parle
souserment de donner des analyses
personnelles on analys personnell c'est
que le gouvernement sortant euh a voulu
en avant de de laisser la place euh
avoir un texte qui puisse exister
c'est-à-dire que le ce décret était
prévu dans la loi euh qui a créé les
cotaxes et euh le gouvernement sortant a
voulu laisser un dossier qui puisse
effectivement euh fonctionner en l'état
encore une fois avec toutes les
imperfections donc
euh il y avait à tel point
d'imperfection que on a on a beaucoup
discuté dans mes services hein pour
préparer ce décret euh qui a été c'est
effectivement très compliqué qui était
difficilement applicable j' j'en
conviens complètement mais il répondait
à la loi telle qu'elle était rédigée et
à tel point que quand le nouveau
gouvernement est arrivé
euh c'est une des premières questions
que m'a posé le le ministre délégué bien
entendu était de me dire mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce décret il est
inapplicable et cetera bon don acte mais
que simplement on a évidemment discuté
avec son cabinet et qu'on s'est aperçu
assez rapidement que c'était la loi qu'
fallait changer et que ce n'était pas un
dispositif réglementaire qui permettait
simple qui aurait permis d'être d'écrire
et de transcrire cette ce souhait
effectivement qu'il a un système de
répercussion qui s'est finalement
transformé en majoration donc voilà la
cette récussion retardé le le
l'exécution du contrat
aomou ça c'est un sujet avec les
transporteurs uniquement voilà non
non voilà ça voir qu'avec les
transporteurs pas du tout et encore une
fois je je pense que si
transporteurs ceux qui qui passent com
je je je je peux que que redire que si
le décret initial est sorti très très
tard c'est qu'effectivement on avait
beaucoup de difficultés en interne à
l'administration et avec nos cabinets de
l'époque de rédiger quelque chose qui
permette d'appliquer la loi ça c'est
c'est tout à fait exact et que c'est à
tel point qu'effectivement quand on a
voulu mettre quelque chose de plus clair
on a changé on a proposé au ministre de
changer la loi ce qui a été fait donc
début
2013 voilà vous avez donc pu suivre une
audition devant la commission d'enquête
sur la mise en place de l'écotax poids
lourd tout de suite la suite de nos
programmes sur Public
Sénat